bonjour heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du 78 lactu sur
TVfil le journal de la rédaction voici
les titres de ce vendredi Michel Kiri
jeune homme de 21 ans converti à l'islam
comparaissait devant la justice ce matin
il s'était opposé le 18 juillet au
contrôle de sa femme enentement voilée 3
mois de prison avec surc était requis
vous entendrez le délibéré des juges
dans quelques minutes la mobilisation
des lycéens des étudiants pour réclamer
l'arrêt des expulsions de jeunes
étrangers scolarisés semble s'essouffler
après les vacances les syndicats
promettaient pourtant des manifestations
d'ampleur la parole sera donnée en
plateau au responsable de l'UNF A51 en
il et puis nous terminerons ce journal
avec les travaux du nouveau centre de
football en salle qui va ouvrir ses
portes à Guill en cours début 2014 un
concept l'Urban foot qui séduit de plus
en plus les sages-femmes reçu par la
ministre de la Santé Marie sol Touren
hier jeudi en fin de journée à l'issue
d'une manifestation de plusieurs
milliers d'entre elles en grève depuis
le 16 octobre tout en poursuivant leur
mission elles ont obtenu la mise en
place d'un groupe de travail qui doit se
réunir à la fin du mois de novembre au
plus tard le 19 c'est la première date
qui a été avancée la réunion doit
permettre de conforter leur rôle et leur
mission Marie sol Tourel la ministre
était d'ailleurs ce matin ce vendredi
matin à poissie pour visiter la
maternité elle dit avoir entendu la
forte demande de reconnaissance de cette
profession eux aussi étaient mobilisés
cette semaine les avocats du Barreau de
Versailles se sont réunis au palais de
justice de la ville pour protester
contre la réforme du financement de
l'aide juridictionnelle c'était ce mardi
il dénonce la baisse de budget et
réclament un dialogue avec Christian
tobira les explications d'Olivier Manis
calco et d'éo moine depuis
Versailles les avocats du Barreau de
Versailles en colère ce mardi il se
réunissait symboliquement au palais de
justice pour protester contre le
désengagement de l'État dans le
financement de l'aide juridictionnelle
cette aide permet à tous d'accéder à la
justice et d'être défendu par un avocat
financé par l'État avec 30 millions
d'euros à louer en moins dès 2015 pour
cette aide les avocats ne s'y
retrouveraient plus financièrement il
redoute également que sans financement
les dossiers bénéficiant de cette aide
juridictionnelle soi traité sans
considération et confié à des avocats
sans expérience la balance de la justice
serait donc menacée le problème de la
juridictionnel c'est que ça fait 10 ans
que les questions sont posées et qu'il
n'y a aucune solution qui n'a été ré par
l'État alors que la profession a fait
des propositions excessivement sérieuses
la seule réforme qui avait été envisagée
était de faire une taxe sur le chiffre
d'affaires des avocats c'est que c'était
aux avocats de financer sur leur
activité l'accès au droit ce qui est
totalement invraisemblable c'était comme
si on demandait au médecin de payer sur
leurs honoraires les soins qu'ils
allaient prodiguer à leurs patients les
avocats réclament aujourd'hui une
concertation avec la ministre de la
Justice Christiane tobira concernant le
financement de cette aide
juridictionnelle de leur côté il propose
d'instaurer une taxe sur les actes
juridique pour assurer leur
rémunération forte semaine de
contestation sag-femme avocat et aussi
filière équestre dans leur ligne de mire
une hausse de la TVA annoncée au 1er
janvier qui pourrait passer de 7 à 20 %
une opération escargo ét organisé ce
jeudi entre Saint-Germain ha et
Rambouillet en passant par versaill et
plaisir à l'initiative d'un collectif là
hors de 78 qui regroupe des
professionnels des amateurs des éleveurs
des cavaliers ou encore des enseignants
la hausse de la TVA de 7 à 20 % est
exigé par Bruxelles pour harmoniser les
taux en Europe coup dur pour ces
professionnels et qui rappelleent qu'il
ne dispose d'aucune subvention publique
on n'oublie pas non plus que les
Yvelines restent le premier département
francilien en matière d'activité
équestre il sera donc fortement impacté
nouvelle manifestation prévu par le
comité régional d'équitation ce sera le
11 novembre et au milieu de cette
contestation la gronne des lycé qui
commence à s'essouffler le 9 octobre
dernier leonarda jeune cososovare de 15
ans sans papier était expulsé en
situation irrégulière çaen était suivi
plusieurs manifestations d'étudiants à
l'appel de différents syndicats et
notamment de l'UNEF organisation dont le
responsable sur cquentins en Yveline est
en plateau aujourd'hui bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau Sébastien
ramage responsable UNEF à 5qutin en
Yveline des manifestation il y en a eu à
travers la France et même dans le
département mais avant les vacances ou
depuis il est plus dur de mobiliser oui
alors effectivement il y a pas eu de
mobilisation dans les evelines suite aux
deux appels à la manifestation de l'UNEF
mais aussi des syndicalisens mardi et
jeudi mais on peut quand même constater
qu'il y a une grosse mobilisation
nationale sur ces deux dates en province
notamment avec entre 15000 et 20000
personnes qui se sont mobilisées dans
les grandes villes de province donc et
comment vous expliquez sur le
département des Yvelines que la
mobilisation ne prenne plus que vous
soyez pas en alors bah par rapport à
Paris leselin c'est un département où
les lycées sont très isolés en fin de
compte il y a on n pas dans une
dynamique nationale comme pourrait y
avoir à Paris avec des lycées tous les 1
ou 2 km ici c'est vraiment Mansard par
exemple à saint-sire qui a un lycée au
milieu d'une zone d'habitation très
éloignée des autres lycées donc je pense
c'est l'explication principale mais
lorsque la mobilisation est annoncée
lorsque les revendications sont
annoncées on peut avoir le sentiment que
c'est une cause importante aussi or même
pendant les vacances il a été difficile
de mobiliser même à Paris hein oui bah
c'est notamment ça veut dire quoi qu'il
y a qu'une seule poignée seulement de de
lycéen ou que ce ne sont que les
organisations qui appellent à manifester
et que finalement les lycéens les
étudiants s'en moquent un petit peu
finalement de cette histoire bah si vous
regardez quand même les les
mobilisations les premières qu'il y a eu
avant les vacances c'est quand même une
grosse partie des lycéens qui se sont
mobilisés entre 300 et 400000 lycéens
dans toute la France donc non au
contraire les revendications sont
majoritaires après il faut savoir que
suite à ces mobilisations là avant les
vacances les lycéens ils ont été
réprimandés tant par leur administration
qui ne refusaient d'excuser leur absence
qui parfois leur donn des sanctions et
aussi leurs parents qui n'accepte pas
forcément qu'il descendent dans la rue
et qui ratent des cours ça pas empêcher
des mobilisations sur d'autres causes
les années passées hein ceci dit mais
vous parlez de cette de ces de ces
difficultés qu'auraient les lycéens à
aller manifester pour autant on peut
aussi comprendre la l'attitude des
dirigeants d'établissements qu'ils ne
veulent pas voir leur établissement
bloqué parce que certains établissements
sont bloqués vous cautionnez ça alors il
faut savoir que la plupart des blocages
qu'il y a eu en France sont des blocage
filtrant c'est-à-dire qu'on laisse
passer les élèves les étud la notion
même de blocage EMP empêcher les élèves
d'aller en cours symbolique c'est une
symbolique c'est-à-dire que généralement
on laisse les lycéens rentrer simplement
les poubelles devant sont là pour dire
voilà les lycéens aujourd'hui on se
mobilise mais il faut savoir aussi pas
tous il y en a qui veulent aller en
cours effectivement il y en a qui vont
en cours et qui ne se sentent pas
concernés donc la plupart des lycéens
qui sont en manifestation contrairement
à ce qu'on dit sont des liciens qui se
sentent concernés et qui savent pourquoi
ils se mobilisent justement pourquoi ils
se mobilisent aujourd'hui ceux qui sont
encore mobilisés c'est concernant
leonarda uniquement concernant
l'ensemble de la politique migratoire en
France alors justement le gouvernement a
beaucoup axé toutes ses réponses sur un
simple fait divers donc une réponse par
rapport à la situation propre de
leonarda mouvement est parti de ça aussi
he exactement le mouvement est parti
d'un fait déclencheur mais ensuite il
s'est politisé c'était bien un mouvement
revendicatif donc les lycéens ils étent
avant tout mobilisés pour la
régularisation des jeunes en formation
c'est ce que les syndicats lycéens ont
appelé à faire et c'est ce que les
lycéens disaient dans la rue quand on
aller les interroger vous en tant que
représentant unf aujourd'hui vous
demandez quoi le retour de leonarda de
sa famille alors premièrement bien sûr
le retour de leonarda mais avant tout
une loi une loi qui cadre tout cela pas
simplement une circulaire et bien une
loi qui détermine que lorsqu'un jeune il
est en formation dans la mesure où il
est formé à être un citoyen parce que
c'est ça le rôle de l'école et ben il
devient citoyen automatiquement et que
il puisse rester en France avec sa
famille bien évidemment parce que on
voit bien que c'est impossible pour un
jeune surtout un mineur de rester en
France d'étudier et d'être sans sa
famille bien sûr vous restez sur ce
plateau dans chacune de nos éditions
vous le savez savez vous avez la parole
vous réagissez à l'actualité notre
question aujourd'hui la mobilisation
lycéenne doit-elle se poursuivre autour
de cette affaire leonarda vos réponses
pour moi non souvent
c'est c'est un prétexte en fait pour
faire grève au niveau des lycéens il y a
eu les vacances ils ont arrêté le
mouvement maintenant ils recommencent
pourquoi ils ont pas continué pendant
les vacances oui carrément vaut mieux
travailler à l'école et au moins avoir
des bons diplômes à la fin pour être
tranquille que
s'embêter à rien je pense que c'est une
bonne chose et normalement ils doivent
poursuivre oui effectivement bah oui
pourquoi pas oui des moments où il
retourne en cours où ça pas longtemps
oui ça me dérange pas non pas du tout
pourquoi parce que les lycéens doivent
s'occuper de leurs études et puis de
cesser de s'occuper
de de
problèmes qui ne justifi pas tout ce
Brouis Sébastien ramage de l'UNEF alors
bon pour répondre à cette dame qu'on
vient d'entendre que les lycéens les
étudiants s'occupent de leurs études
malheureusement c'est des réactions que
nous en tant que jeune on a l'habitude
d'entendre quand on nous laisse pas
accès au débat public il faut savoir que
les lycéens ils ont pris énormément de
risques pour se mobiliser la
contrepartie de leur mobilisation sont
des sanctions je l'ai dit précédemment
donc on peut dire que effectivement ils
ont pris des risques et en plus de cela
euh les euh pardon je me suis perdu les
les revendications des lycéens elles
étaient clairement établies depuis le
début et il y a il va pas y avoir de
cons phénoménale sur leur réussite
éducative de se mobiliser quelqu
quelques jours et en plus de ça dernière
chose c'est qu'ils ont quand même donné
un bel exemple de solidarité et de
mobilisation auprès de la société civile
parce qu'on a pas eu de grosse
mobilisation contre le gouvernement
enfin contre sa politique depuis le
début du mandat de François Holland sont
les premiers à être descendu dans la rue
et avoir tiré la sonette d'alarme et
dire que voilà la situation n plus
acceptable et on se mobilise quoi on
entendu aussi dans le micro trottoir
c'est un prétexte pour que les étudiants
les lycéens aillent dans la rue et vous
le savez lorsqu'on va dans les
manifestations on voit des étudiants qui
ne sont pas concernés qui finalement on
sait même pas on voit des MICR trottoir
on écoute ces jeunes parler ils savent
même plus pourquoi ils sont là
aujourd'hui parce qu' il y a eu un
mouvement parce que leurs copains
viennent manifester peut-être que
certains je ne dis pas que certains aent
des revendications mais c'est pas
forcément la majorité de ceux qui sont
dans la rue alors encore une fois c'est
je pense c'est très facile surtout pour
ces gens-là de juger les motifs pour
lesquels les lycéens sont descendent
dans la rue quand il euxmême ils ne font
pas la démarche d'aller leur parler mais
moi ce qui m'énerve quand il y a des
mobilisations lycéennes c'est avant tout
que le débat il c'était pareil il y a il
y a plusieurs années pendant les
retraites où moi j'étais lycéen à
l'époque on va on va toujours leur
demander est-ce que vous êtes légitime à
descendre dans la rue plutôt que de leur
demander pourquoi vous descendez dans la
rue et qu'est-ce que vous revendiquez
pourquoi ils ne sont pas descendus dans
la rue pendant les vacances ses lycéens
et ses étudiants alors il y a plusieurs
facteurs premièrement quand on est dans
un lycée qu'on est entouré de tous ses
amis c'est bien plus facile à mobiliser
que quand on est chez soi ou en vacances
ou même en province avec ses parents
mais la deuxième chose c'est
que les des organisations syndicales qui
structurent tout de même le mouvement
lycéen n'ont pas tout simplement appelé
à la manifestation pendant les vacances
aussi c'est aussi un facteur si on
regarde le fond du dossier concernant
cette expulsion de leonarda 65 % des des
Français affirment être opposé au retour
de l'adolescente interpellé le 9 octobre
dernier lors d'une sortie scolaire et
ben ça confirme encore une nouvelle fois
dans opinion ça semble difficile à faire
comprendre que vous soyez mobilisé
est-ce que c'est défendable le cas
leonarda ça confirme une nouvelle fois
que les lycéens ils donnent un une belle
une belle leçon de solidarité à
l'ensemble des Français parce que en
tant que jeune et ben eux ils sentent
pas forcément concernés par les discours
sur lesmigration que peuvent tenir la
droite l'extrême droite et même certains
membres du gouvernement et donc les
lycéens eux il ils assument clairement
que ils sont solidaires de leurs
compagnons de classe et qui souhait que
ils reste dans le pays il fassent leurs
études dans des bonnes conditions vous
parlez de l'ensemble des étudiants sans
papier mais sur l'affaire leonarda vous
nous dites moi je suis pour qu'elle
revienne avec sa famille et pour autant
elle n'allait pas toujours en cours pour
autant son dossier est difficilement
défendable sur le plan même de la
véacité son père a menti sur pas mal
d'éléments alors si vous voulez on peut
faire un débat sur l'échec scolaire et
sur les raisons qui poussent les
étudiants aujourd'hui ou les lycéens à
ne pas aller en cours mais le débat il
est pas là c'est pas est-ce que leonarda
est une bonne élève ou pas ou pas une
bonne élève est-ce que le débat c'est
surû est-ce que ses parents sont gentils
ou pas gentils c'est pas ça le débat en
fin mais quand vous l'entendez depuis le
Kosovo qui aujourd'hui dit bah en France
il faudrait changer des ministres ces
j'échang qu'elle a eu même directement
avec François Hollande vous trouvez que
c'est bon pour la République pour
l'image aussi de la France elle est cé
on va pas de toute façon faire un
tribunal à l'ensemble des collégiens et
leur demande ce qui se passe à propos de
la politique de François Hollande c'est
une collégienne c'est une enfant il faut
pas oublier et un enfant ben ça a le
droit d'aller à l'école d'aller
àricoolle de la République et d'être
formé à être un citoyen comme tous les
enfants de ce pays on parlait de la
difficulté à mobiliser aussi ne
serait-ce que dans les ivelines tout de
même déjà au niveau des autres
contestations il y en a beaucoup
actuellement est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment aussi que votre cause est plus
difficile aussi à faire entendre au
milieu des contestations contre les
taxes diverses et varié on parlait des
squestres on a parlé des avocats aussi
tout à l'heure des sages femmes aussi
qui sont dans la rue les enseignants la
semaine prochaine aussi alors je pense
quand même qu'on a été entendu parce que
moi personnellement j'ai jamais vu un
président faire une interview en direct
à la télévision pour réagir par rapport
à un simple fait divers il n pas du tout
réagi par rapport à un fait divers il a
réagi par rapport à une mobilisation
c'est le président de la République
lui-même qui va sur un plateau télé et
qui réagit par rapport au mouvement
c'est bien la preuve que les lycéens par
leur mobilisation et ben ils ont fait
peur ils ont poser un rapport de force
et en plus de ça ils ont été reçus dans
les différents ministères pour être
entendus comment le mouvement va se
poursuivre appel à une nouvelle semaine
d'action à partir de de lundi selon la
fidèle le syndicat lycéen alors la
fidèle va se concerter avec l'ensemble
des autres organisation et pour
l'instant les décisions n'ont pas encore
été prises donc c'est pas à moi
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de déterminer
s'ils vont ou pas poursuivre leur
mobilisation en r l'UNF quel est le mot
d'ordre en revanche à l'UNEF nous on
continue le travail qui se fait après la
la Mobil c'està-dire donner un déboucher
politique aux revendications des jeunes
et donc ça ça se fait en concertation
avec les différents ministères les
acteurs de de l'État donc pour
déterminer qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour les jeunes en formation merci
Sébastien ramage d'être venu sur ce
plateau responsable UNEF à Saint-Quentin
en uveline et vous nous dites que la
mobilisation devrait tout de même se
poursuivre malgré tout même s'il reste
encore des points à éclaircir avec les
différents participants notamment le
syndicat lycéen la fidèle on reste dans
le domaine de l'éducation pour vous dire
qu'au clés sousbois l'école Victor Hugo
a enfin puré ouvrir ses porte il aura
fallu plus de 3 ans pour voir
l'établissement accueillir à nouveau des
écoliers aujourd'hui il ne reste plus
aucune trace de l'incendie criminel qu'
l'avait détruite en avril 2010 lundi
matin enseignants et élèves ont
découvert les lieux et puis pour vous
dire également qu'attpe la suspension de
la réforme des rythme scolaire n'est pas
d'actualité la municipalité et son maire
guim Malandin ont répondu à la demande
de l'association unap l'association
indépendante des parents d'élèves par un
courrier en date du 15 octobre une
réponse simple en trois lettres non il
demande au président de cette
organisation que nous avions d'ailleurs
reçu sur ce plateau de se montrer plus
constructif et de ne pas faire de
propagande politicienne fin de citation
trappe justement on y reste cet été des
émeutes vous le savez il y avait éclaté
la conséquence de l'interpellation d'un
jeune homme et de sa femme portant un
voile intégral dont le contrôle
d'identité s'était mal passé Michell
Kiris c'est le nom de ce jeune homme
comparaissait devant la justice à
Versailles ce vendredi matin il a été
condamné à 3 mois de pr mais avec surcis
et 1000 € d'amende pour rébellion et
outrage on retrouve yolen Torz et
Jonathan villman au tribunal
correctionnel pour plus de
précisions l'affaire avait été le point
de départ de 3 nuits de violence en
juillet dernier à trappe Michel Kiri 21
ans a été condamné à 3 mois de prison
avec surcis et 1000 € d'amende par le
tribunal correctionnel de Versailles le
jeune homme originaire de sa saint était
accusé d'avoir tenté d'étrangler un
policier le 18 juillet lors du contrôle
idtité de sa femme entièrement voilée
son avocat demande la réouverture des
débats en faisant appel il affirme que
des éléments nouveaux ont été révélé par
une enquête de
l'IGPN la défense entendait poser des
questions de nouvelles questions au
trois partis civil puisque un des trois
policiers était entendu au cours de
cette enquête la défense voulait faire
de nouvelles observations sur ces faits
nouveaux puisque je le répète ce sont
des faits qui contribueront
incontestablement à la manifestation de
la vérité nous n'avons pas eu la
possibilité de le faire nous allons donc
faire appel et devant la cour d'appel
nous verserons au débat ces nouveaux
éléments et nous poserons les questions
que nous avons pas pu poser aujourd'hui
à son procès Michel Kiri avait affirmé
trouver le contrôle d'identité
illégitime pour l'avocat des policiers
cette condamnation est une satisfaction
d'après lui c'est un rappel ferme par le
Tribunal qu'en France c'est la loi de la
République française qui s'applique
quant à l'appel demandé par la défense
il parle de manipulation ah mais c'est
une manipulation qui est totalement
assumé c'est une manipulation c'est elle
est tellement grossière que elle est
assumée c'est voilà des gens qui vous
disent vous critiquez notre
religion donc vous n'avez pas le droit
donc nous allons faire appel faire du
cupess et cetera mais qu'il le fasse
notre système démocratique le leur en
offre la possibilité je me réjouis qu'il
puisse le faire mais je me réjouis aussi
que nos institutions soient fermes et ne
fassent pas prospérer des arguments qui
ne sont pas des arguments religieux qui
sont des arguments politiques le procès
de la femme de Michel Kiri Cassandra
Belin a quant à lui ét renvoyé au 11
décembre l'autre actualité de cette
semaine c'est la présence sur les routes
du département de nouveau radar ils sont
capables de flasher les véhicules qui
circulent dans les deux sens les
nouveaux radars embarqués sont en
service il fonctionnent comme l'ont
constaté Antony R et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud vous l'avez peut-être croisé sans
vous en rendre compte le radar nouvelle
génération roule dans les ivelines
installé dans un véhicule banalisé en
mouvement le système peut contrôler des
véhicules dans les deux sens de
circulation et jusqu'à quatre voies
parallèles sauf en cas de terreplein
central il est indétectable par les
avertisseurs de radar mais surtout par
les automobilistes l'idée la philosophie
de ce dispositif c'est de créer au PO
des usagers de la route un sentiment
d'insécurité non pas négatif mais qui
est plutôt destiné à à les rendre
vigilant sur leur propre conduite leur
propre comportement sur leur
environnement de manière à bien sûr
essayer toujours et encore de faire
diminuer le nombre de tués sur les
routes mais qui dit nouvelle génération
dit budget ce nouveau système coûte
70000 € et un seul véhicle sera équipé
dans le département autre aspect la
marge de tolérance est augmentée de 5 km
he pour les radars classiques cela passe
à 10 kmh jusqu'à 100 km he et 10 % Audel
ainsi les petits excès de vitesse ne
sont pas pris en compte là comme vous
pouvez voir le radar a flé un véhicule
qui en sens inverse de nous il roulait à
106 kmh pour une vitesse de
donc cette personne va recevoir laave de
contravention chez elle
à savoir donc une amende à 45 € et un
retrait de 1 point et pour être flashé
il doit y avoir un écart de vitesse de
20 kmh entre les deux véhicules lors de
notre essai d'une vingtaine de minutes
le radar a contrôlé 83 automobilistes
pour quatre infractions répertorié
depuis le début de l'année 46 personnes
ont trouvé la mort sur les routes
ivlinoises dont les 2 tiers à cause
d'excès de
vitesse le taux de vaccination contre la
grippe en perpétuelle chute depuis les
inquiétudes suscitées par le vaccin
contre l'épidémie H1 N1 et c'est
pourtant loin d'être une maladie anodine
cette grippe la Caisse Primaire
d'Assurance Maladie lance d'ailleurs une
campagne nationale de communication pour
relancer la vaccination justement je
sors de de la pharmacie j'ai acheté un
un vaccin pour me faire vacciner ça va
être la toute première fois que je vais
me faire vacciner ils ne sont pas
nombreux comme cette femme à faire le
choix de la vaccination contre la grippe
seulement 50 % des Français dit à risque
femmes enceintes personnes âgées en
surpoids ou asthmatique se protège
régulièrement contre une maladie qui
entraîne pourtant 6000 décès chaque
année en France il est très difficile
d'avoir les chiffres précis euh on
estime dans le monde que c'est à peu
près un demi milillion de personnes par
an quand même en France c'est
probablement quelques dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui meurent chaque
année des conséquences de la grippe donc
ça vaut largement le coup de les
protéger en général la grippe se
caractéris souvent par des températures
assez élevées et une survenue très
brutale ainsi que la présence de douleur
musculaire et c'est contre les idées
reçues qu'il faut lutter le plus souvent
non le vaccin ne donne pas la grippe et
oui une nouvelle vaccination est
nécessaire tous les ans en raison des
mutations du virus dans cette pharmacie
on constate tout de même que le message
commence à passer j'ai pas regardé mes
stocks mes sorti mais vu quand j'ouvre
le réfrigérateur parce que les vaccins
card au réfrigérateur quand je regarde
je pense que j'en ai vendu plus que
l'année dernière 10 à 20 % de plus le
vaccin coûte à peine plus de 6 €
remboursé à 70 % il est gratuit pour les
personnes à risque notamment celles de
plus de 65 ans 225000 assuré dans les
yvelin ont ainsi reçu un bon de prise en
charge il faut attendre une quinzaine de
jours après la piqûre pour être
immunisé après la santé une page sport
en février 2014 un nouveau centre de
football en salle va ouvrir ses portes à
Guill en cours 8 terrains de foot à 5
vont être construits le concept lancé en
2005 séduit de plus en plus les cit
comme nous l'explique Antony
Resche le terrain est grillager il n'y a
pas de touche pas de temps mort au foot
urbain la partbelle est faite au
spectacle au geste technique et au but
sur 30 m par 20 de large aussi bien les
footballeurs du dimanche que les
professionnels du passement de jambe
s'affrontent en 5 contre 5 mais sans
oublier la 3è mi-temps au club aous
c'est avant tout du football c'est une
version ludique loisir du football donc
c'est accessible à à tout le monde donc
on des enfants des
adultes et on s'amuse quel que soit son
niveau puisque c'est plus facile parce
que le ballon reste dans l'air de jeu
avec les palissades à Guill encour Urban
Football ouvrira son premier complexe
dans les ivelines les amateurs de
ballonrond pourront profiter de H
terrains synthétiques quatre indoor et
quatre à l'extérieur après un premier
centre à plutôt dans les hautes scènes
l'entreprise créée en 2005 a ouvert neu
autrocites dont un en Belgique
maisiguille en cours est le premier
Urban Football bâti sur un partenariat
public privé au fot urbain la séance
d'une heure coûte 12 € par personne
chaque semaine un centre accueille
environ 5000 footballeurs le complexe de
guillencour devrait ouvrir ses portes en
février
2014 et on va donc attendre le printemps
pour aller pratiquer l'urbane football
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve mardi puisque lundi nous serons
le 11 novembre jour de commémoration de
fin de la Grande Guerre et à cette
occasion sachez d'ailleurs que le 1er
décembre la Roy Factory à versaill
programme une représentation de ce soir
il pleuvera des étoiles un spectacle
théâtral et musical d'Alexandre Martin
varois qui revisite le passé et trois
grands conflits qui ont marqué
l'histoire contemporaine et les relation
franco-allemande le tout sur un style
jazzy c'est à 16h le 1er décembre au
profit de l'œeuvre des pupilles
orphelins et fond entraide des sapeurs
pompiers de France en voici un
extrait dans les
de
fr les frour il rêve l'amour le soir
sous la SER c'est tout de la terre qui
Tom bonne saison pour les volc on va
faire sauter le monde tremplez-vous
tout il n'y fait pas bon ici en
arrière ce sont les avions qui font des
ravages
terribles ma bouffarde c'est Victorine
ouais le masque à gaz c'est Gaston ma
gamelle c'est Ernestine mon flagau c'est
Cupidon ma cartouchière c'est pichnette
mon calot c'est btitin ma capote c'est
néette mon bidon c'est Rin Tintin
reviensmi mon
amour le temps passe le temps
cou et mon armâme te réclame nuit et
jours ce soir il pleuvera des étoiles le
1er décembre à Versailles très bon
weekend sur TVfil et à Mardi 18h en
direct